people often kind of wonder
world-class researchers such as yourself
what kind of
books technical fiction philosophical
were
had an impact on you in your life and uh
maybe
ones you could probably possibly
recommend
that others read maybe if you have three
books that pop into mind
yeah so i definitely liked judea pearl's
book
probabilistic reasoning and intelligence
systems it's um
it's a very deep technical book but what
i liked is that
so there are many uh places where you
can learn about
probabilistic graphical models from but
throughout this book judea pulls
kind of sprinkles his philosophical
observations and
and he thinks about connections to how
the brain thinks
and attentions and resources all those
things so so that whole thing
makes it more interesting to read he
emphasizes the importance of causality
so that was in his later book so this
was the first book probabilistic
reasoning in interlin systems he
mentions causality but he hadn't really
sunk his teeth into
like you know how do you actually
formalize yeah and uh the second book
causality
is the 2001 uh the one in two thousand
that one is really hard so i wouldn't
recommend that uh
uh yes so that looks at the like the
mathematical like
his model of uh do calculus yeah it was
pretty dense mathematically right right
right uh the book of why is definitely
more enjoyable oh for sure yeah
um so yeah so i would i would recommend
probabilistic reasoning in interleaving
systems
another book i liked uh was uh one from
doug huff starter uh this is a long time
ago though here's a book
he had a book i think called it was
called the mind's eye it was
um uh probably half starter
and daniel dennett together yeah so
and i actually was uh i i bought that
book it's on my show i haven't read it
yet
but i uh i couldn't get an electronic
version of it which is annoying because
i'm
you read everything on kindle okay uh
so you had to actually purchase the
physical it's like one of the only
physical books i have because yeah
anyway there's a lot of people
recommended it highly so
yeah and the third one uh i would
definitely recommend reading is
um uh this is not a technical book it is
history it's called it's the name of the
book i think is bishop's voice
it's about wright brothers and uh and
their
their their path and how it was
uh it's there are multiple books on this
topic
and all of them are great it's um
uh fascinating how a
flight was uh you know treated as an
unsolvable problem
and and and also you know what aspects
did people
emphasize uh you know people thought oh
it is all about
the just powerful engines you know just
need to have powerful lightweight
engines
uh and um so
you know some people thought of it as
how far can we just throw the thing you
know
just through it catapult yeah so
uh so it is it's a very fascinating and
even after they
uh made the invention of people not
believing it and uh
the social aspect of it is the social
aspect it's a different
you know very important do you uh draw
any parallels between
you know birds fly so there's the
natural approach
to uh to flight and then there's the
engineered approach
do you um do you see the same kind of
thing with the brain
and are trying to engineer intelligence
yeah it's it's a good analogy to have uh
of course all analogies have their you
know yeah
so for sure so people in uh you know ai
often uh use airplanes
as an example of hey we didn't learn
anything from birds look right there
yeah
but the the funny thing is that uh and
and the
saying is uh airplanes don't flap wings
yeah right this is what
they say the funny thing and the ironic
thing is that
that you don't need to flap to fly
is something right brothers found by
observing birds
yeah so they have in their notebook you
know in some of these uh books they show
their notebook drawings right they they
make detailed
notes about buzzards uh just soaring
over the thermals
and they basically say look flapping is
not
the important propulsion is not the
important problem to solve here
we want to solve control uh and uh once
you solve control propagation will fall
into place
all of these are people you know they re
realize this by observing birds
beautifully put that's actually
brilliant uh because people do
use that analogy a lot i'm gonna have to
remember that one
you